♪
>> Laura: THE PENNSYLVANIA
REPUBLICAN SENATE PRIMARY'S
RIGHT NOW THE HOTTEST POLITICAL
RACE IN AMERICA.
THE INGRAHAM ANGLE IS DOING ITS
PART TO MAKE SURE THE NEARLY 26%
OF VOTERS WHO SAY THEY'RE STILL
UNDECIDED LESS THAN A WEEK
BEFORE THE ELECTION GET THE
CHANCE TO SEE THE CANDIDATES
THEMSELVES.
LAST NIGHT IN OUR RETAKING
AMERICA SERIES WE PROFILED KATHY
BARNETTE AND BOY IS THE GOP OPPO
ON HER FLOWING.
THEN THERE'S DR. OZ, WE HAVE OUR
ISSUES WITH HIM BUT HE HAS AN
OPEN INVITATION TO COME ON THIS
SHOW AS WELL.
TONIGHT WE TURN TO DAVE
McCORMACK WHO ALWAYS FINDS
HIMSELF NEAR THE TOP OF THE HEAP
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
DAVE GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
WHY ARE SO MANY VOTERS, SIX DAYS
OUT, I KNOW THERE'S ALREADY MAIL
IN BALLOTS COMING IN AND EARLY
VOTING, BUT WHY SO MANY STILL
UNDECIDED?
>> WELL, LISTEN, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME LAURA.
I'M TRAVELING ACROSS THE STATE
MEETING EVERY DAY AND
PENNSYLVANIANS ARE SO FOCUSED ON
THIS.
THEY'RE ANGRY.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEIR COUNTRY'S
SLIPPING AWAY AND THEY'RE ZEROED
IN ON THE CANDIDATES AND I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT THING AND THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR SOMEONE WHO CAN GO
FIGHT FOR THEM IN WASHINGTON.
AND THEY LOOK AT ME AS SOMEONE
WHO'S BATTLE TESTED SERVED IN
THE MILITARY GREW UP IN
PENNSYLVANIA CREATED JOBS AND I
FEEL MOMENTUM ON THE GROUND WHEN
I DO THESE MEETINGS AND I THINK
YOU'LL SEE OVER THE NEXT FEW
DAYS THAT UNDECIDED ELECTORATE
IS GOING TO BEGIN TO ZERO IN ON
WHO THEY BELIEVE CAN LEAD THE
FIGHT IN WASHINGTON AND I
BELIEVE THAT WILL BE ME.
>> Laura: THE SENATE HAS NOW
AGREED TO LIFT TRUMP TARIFFS ON
CHINA.
WE HAVE A $400 BILLION DEFICIT
WITH CHINA ON TRADE THIS YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S LOOKING LIKE
IT'S GOING TO BE.
DAVE, WHAT ABOUT THE TARIFFS?
WILL YOU VOTE, WOULD YOU SUPPORT
LIFTING THE TARIFFS ONS THESE
CHINESE GOODS WHEN THEY HAVE
RENEGED ON THEIR PROMISE TO BUY
$200 BILLION WORTH OF OUR
AGRICULTURE?
>> NO, I WOULD NOT SUPPORT
LIFTING THE TARIFFS.
AND I WOULD BE A LEADER OF A
STRATEGY AND A POSTURE WITH
CHINA THAT WOULD EVEN GO BEYOND
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
AND AS SOMEONE WHO IS -- SPENT
NINE YEARS OF HIS LIFE FIGHTING
COMMUNIST IDEOLOGY NEGOTIATED AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT AGAINST CHINA AND DID
BUSINESS AROUND THE WORLD NO ONE
HAS THE EXPERIENCE I HAVE TO GO
TOE TO TOE WITH CHINA.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE A BUNCH
OF STRONG VOICE ONS CHINA LIKE
MIKE POMPEO POM LIKE TED CRUZ
WHO SPEARHEADED MY CAMPAIGN.
WE NEED SOMEBODY IN THE SENATE
WHO HAS THE EXPERIENCE TO GO TOE
TO TOE WITH CHINA AND I HAVE
THAT.
>> Laura: THE CRITICISM OF YOU
DAVIS THAT YOU'RE IN THE POCKET
OF CHINA.
I KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME HARD
AT YOU IN THAT RALLY WITH OZ
LAST WEEK AND YOU SAY TO THAT?
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU LIKE TRUMP.
SO WHAT GIVES?
>> YEAH.
LISTEN, I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU KNOW, I'VE SPENT MY LIFE
SERVING OUR GREAT COUNTRY IN THE
MILITARY, AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT.
AND EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP KNOWS
THAT, HE ASKED ME TO BE HIS
DEPUTY DEFENSE SECRETARY.
SO I THINK MY CREDENTIALS AS
SOMEONE WHO'S STRONG ON CHINA
ARE BEYOND DISPUTE AND I'VE DONE
BUSINESS AROUND THE WORLD LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD DONE IN
RUSSIA AND CHINA AND THAT
EXPERIENCE WILL MAKE ME A MUCH
STRONGER SENATOR.
AND I KNOW BETTER THAN ANYONE
THAT WE NEED A STRATEGY THAT
GOES TOE TO TOE WITH CHINA, THE
ECONOMIC RISKS AND NATIONAL
SECURITY RISKS ARE SIGNIFICANT
AND WE NEED TO HAVE A POSTURE
THAT REALLY BRINGS AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP TO THE WORLD AND
CHANGES OUR REELING SUMP CHINA
AND I CAN BE A LEADER ON THAT.
>> Laura: DAVE WHY DO YOU THINK
BARNETT'S SURGING.
YOU AND OZ WERE THE TWO BIG DOGS
FOR THE LONGEST TIME AND THEN
SUDDENLY THIS WOMAN NO ONE KNOWS
ANYTHING ABOUT IS YOU HAD KNELL
THE TOP 3.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> WELL, LISTEN, SHE'S GETTING
HER DAY IN THE SUN BUT I THINK
WHAT VOTERS ARE ASKING
THEMSELVES, AND THIS RACE IS SO
IMPORTANT LAURA YOU KNOW THIS
BETTER THAN ANYBODY, THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIND A CANDIDATE THAT,
A, HAS THEIR VALUES, B, CAN WIN
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
THIS RACE COULD NOT BE MORE
IMPORTANT.
AND THEN CAN GO TO WASHINGTON
AND FIGHT FOR AN AMERICA FIRST
AGENDA.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE TESTS THAT
EVERY CANDIDATE HAS TO GO TO.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE BEING
SCRUTINIZED ON AND KATHY I'VE
GOTTEN TO KNOW HAD ER ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL SHE HAS A GREAT
STORY BUT SHE'S BEEN TESTED.
LAST TWO YEARS SHE RAN FOR
CONGRESS AND LOST BY 20 POINTS.
WE CAN'T TAKE A RISK ON THIS
SEAT.
>> Laura: WOW.
>> WE HAVE TO WIN THIS SEAT AND
WE HAVE TO GO HEAD TO HEAD WITH
JOHN FETTERMAN RIGHT THE STAKES
ARE SO HIGH.
>> Laura: THE REPUBLICANS CANNOT
LOSE THIS.
YOU CAN'T TAKE A RISK.
NOW DAVE BREAKING MOMENTS AGO
BIDEN'S INTERIOR DEPARTMENT JUST
ANNOUNCED THEY ARE CANCELLING
PLANNED OIL AND GAS LEASE SALES
IN THE GULF OF MEXICO AND
ALASKA'S COOK INLET.
VERY BRIEFLY YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT.
JUST BROKE.
>> IT'S MORE OF THE WAR ON
ENERGY.
IT'S BEEN A DISASTER FOR OUR
COUNTRY, DISASTER FOR
PENNSYLVANIA.
IT'S KILLED US ECONOMICALLY,
IT'S SACRIFICED OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AND IT'S HURT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND IT IS BEYOND DISPUTE THAT
THE BIDEN POLICIES HAVE FAILED.
WE HAVE TO HAVE ENERGY
DOMINANCE, WE CAN LEAD THE WORLD
IN ENERGY, GREAT FOR
PENNSYLVANIA AND OUR COUNTRY AND
AS A SENATOR FOR PENNSYLVANIA,
THIS WOULD BE MY NUMBER ONE
AGENDA ITEM BECAUSE THIS IS THE
KEY TO UNLOCKING THE POTENTIAL
IN PENNSYLVANIA WHICH IS REALLY
REMARKABLE.
>> Laura: THE STEEL INDUSTRY IN
PENNSYLVANIA, ALL THOSE WORKERS,
THEY NEED SOMEONE WHO'S GOING TO
FIGHT FOR THEM.